alors il ya un passage qui absolument
stupéfiant dans votre vie c'est qu'à un
certain moment vous dites moi qui ai
vécu à buchenwald
trente ans après je ne suis pas sûr de
ne pas avoir rêvé je suis pas sûr
finalement mes souvenirs alors que j'ai
l'impression que lorsque je pense au
goulag
j'ai l'impression qu effectivement j'y
étais ça paraît stupéfiant ce nom si
vous voyez les ouvriers les souvenirs de
de toute une série d'écrivains qui ont
été déportés ou sentiment là est
absolument identique dans les lettres le
journal de cause et sauf
le joint de condamnés à mort qui était
qui sort d'un goulag beaucoup plus
récent puisqu'il a été libéré il n'y a
même pas un an d'un camp brejnéviens
vous trouverez la même idée l'idée que
finalement de ce prêtre en rêve dans les
livres de l'italien qui a écrit deux
livres superbe sur la déportation en
allemagne primo levi vous trouverez
exactement la même idée et même à dornes
look et de philosophes qui n'a jamais
été déporté dans le dernier chapitre de
sa dialectique négative il parle ce qui
serait d'ailleurs après à auschwitz il
parle de ce sentiment là comme le
sentiment qu'il a construit comme un
concept parce que c'est une chose
possible je crois que c'est tout à fait
je dois fait normal de ne pas savoir
quelle est la vie réelle celle celle du
camp ou celle d'après d'avant c'est pas
donc une idée littéraire suis désolé
c'est du vécu la veille
alors si vous faites la différence entre
les camps riscle est rien et les camps
staliniens c'est que vous dites au fond
dans les camps était rien on savait
qu'ils on avait en face
je ne fais pas la différence je crois
que général ont réagi d'une façon
complètement ai dit c'est pas comparable
je dis oui c'est tout à fait comparable
ce tout à fait comparable s'est
historiquement comparables et c'est
moralement comparable mais c'est
techniquement comparable pour arriver à
la conclusion que les camps du goulag
était bien pire
de multiples raisons au trop long à
expliquer peut-être bien d'abord pour
une raison évidente c'est que nous
étions les ennemis du régime nazi
c'était donc logique qu'on choisit
certaine façon aux déportés on savait à
qui elles avaient affaire où il est
tellement il y avait eu et nouer avec
eux et nous mais les déportés la plupart
l'immense majorité des déportés dans les
camps staliniens étaient déportés là ou
bien parce qu'ils étaient des des
soi-disant koulaks c'est-à-dire déportés
en temps en tant que classe en tant que
paysan ou en tant que juif à dire que
pour moi c'était un peu comme le comme
la déportation des juifs en fonction de
leur judéité pas vu résistance
quelconque d'un ou des innocents
vraiment des innocents sans guillemets
les gens qui étaient là sans raison donc
il savait pas où il était il n'avait pas
d'autres qui se battre il fallait
vraiment il ya des exceptions bien
entendu changé et il en est une il a
élaboré une théorie de la résistance
dans le dans les camps qui recoupe
d'ailleurs celle que nous avons vécue
élaboré nous mêmes mais dans les
conditions mais c'était beaucoup plus
difficile je pense je lui dis des ondes
lamoulie où je pense que la seule
comparaison possible l'aurait été si la
purge des ssd à la fraction plébéienne
dijon de peu gauche antrim et du nazisme
avait provoqué des centaines des
milliers d'arrestations que cc hitlérien
séides zahia aurait été à six avaient
été déportés internés eugeot riz ce
sentiment d'injustice et
d'incompréhension
le joueur ne sais pas ce qu'ils arrivent
comme les autres disait staline ne sait
pas ce qui nous arrive et les cce aurait
été les pires à l'umih comparables et
puis à une autre une autre raison pour
lequel les camps sont pire c'est que
techniquement matériellement ils sont
pires
il suffit de lire les témoignages et on
ne peut pas la mettre en doute qui se
recoupent tous le puits depuis l'été
puis trente ans sur le camp russe pour
voir que la situation matérielle la
façon de vivre la façon de manger la
façon de se coucher de se couvrir
c'était pire oui enfin
écoutez tout au long de ce beau livre il
y a tout de même le signe le signe de ce
fanatisme permanent quotidien du camp
c'est à dire la fumée du crématoire
oui mais le crématoire attention je vais
essayer de me comprendre les crématoires
n'est pas n'est pas en lui-même horrible
autrement que comme symbole le
crématoire c'est l'application de la
rationalité capitalistes allemands à la
solution du problème des cadavres il y
en a plusieurs centaines par jour il
faut les liquider l'espace n'est pas
comme dans le grand nord sibérien est
fini il faut résoudre ce problème et la
technique allemande invente le
crématoire comme elle invente la chambre
à gaz pour liquider la question juive
le crématoire c'est ça mais évidemment
nous le vivons autrement mais je veux
dire que ce n'est pas que c'est pire
d'être incinérés ou d'être enterré dans
la neige éternelle
qu'est ce qui est pire c'est la mort qui
est terrible ce n'est pas le fait que
l'on soit brûlé après ou pas ces
milliers ces dizaines de milliers les
centaines de milliers de russes qui sont
enterrés dans les neiges éternelles et
qui sont la fihg pour toujours pour
l'éternité comme raconte chalamov bon
ils sont là ce sont les témoins de tout
ça pour nous le témoin c'était la fumée
des crématoires
et puis donc mémoire politique mémoire
historique et puis mémoire littéraire
parce que ce camp de buchenwald ce
plateau balayé par le vent et la neige
est aussi un haut lieu de littérature
allemand et oui c'est l'endroit où se
promenaient goûter avec hermann c'est
l'endroit napoléon avait des entrevues
ce l'endroit où sont passé plein de
choses et puis c'est l'endroit où léon
blum a été enfermé pas avec nous dans le
cadre d'une villa mais à côté dans
l'enceinte même du camp et léon blum et
l'auteur d'abord un ami mais ensuite
reconnu les nouvelles conversations de
gaieté avec hermann donc c'était
vraiment assez tentant d'utiliser tous
solidaires vous